have rihanna and drake called it quits  after teasing fans with their on  again-off again relationship for years  the two superstars have reportedly split  after one month of being official one  source told E news they are seeing other  people another insider tells Us Weekly  Rihanna doesn't want to be held down but  according to people Drake and RiRi never  actually broke up because the  relationship has always been open  besides Rihanna appears to be just fine  on her own she was spotted on Monday  night headed to a nightclub solo in New  York City an eyewitness tells ET re  partied alone and stayed out until four  in the morning last week the singer also  through some serious shade at her ex's  with this pointed message none of my  exes are happy or in happy relationships  so it's safe to say that I wasn't the  problem well Rihanna and Drake might  have their first run-in at this year's  American Music Awards they are the most  and a second most nominated artist  respectively  you